ja willkommen zur digitalen
ersatzsitzung im Seminar Ethik des
anthropozäns wir haben es heute mit zwei
Denkern zu tun wir gehen erst noch mal
auf Hans Jonas ein auf seine Schrift das
Prinzip Verantwortung und dann gehen wir
über auf Vittorio Hösle der ein Schüler
von Hans Jonas war und schauen wir an
ihn anknüpft er noch mal zu Hans Jonas
so sieht er aus und er hat ein Buch
geschrieben das Prinzip Verantwortung
Versuch einer Ethik für die
technologische Zivilisation im
surkampfverlag
erschienen und aus diesem Werk haben wir
schon einiges gelesen wir wollen aber
dennoch hier ein paar Blicke noch mal
hineinwerfen um so einen Hintergrund zu
bekommen vor dem dann die Philosophie
von Vittorio Hösle
Auftritt ich bringe jetzt hier ein paar
Zitate in den ich die wichtigsten
Passagen meinen Augen fett markiert hat
wir hatten gesehen Hans Jonas sagt dass
die Natur Zwecke unterhält natürch die
belebte Natur ein Stein verfolgt keinen
Zweck es geht um Organismen sie verfolgt
Zwecke sie hat Ziele und sie setzt
deswegen auch Werte das ist dieses
Argument von ihm dass es sagt aus
Zwecken aus Zielen folg Werte weil das
Erreichen dieses Ziels ein unters macht
im Gegensatz zum nicht erreichen oder
auch zur nicht Existenz das ist also so
sein Argument wir schauen s noch mal ein
bisschen genauer an also die
Zielstrebigkeit oder auch die Teleologie
von griechisch tellos Ziel das
zielstreben das ist für ihn eine
Selbstbejahung des Seins also der
Organismus der nach etwas strebt z.B
eine Pflanze die zum Licht hinstrebt
oder auch ein tierischer Organismus der
sich wieder regeneriert oder auch
reproduziert der ist als selbstbejahrung
zu verstehen nach Hans Jonas und das ist
das absolut bessere gegenüber dem nicht
sein seiner nicht
Existenz in jedem Zweck erklärt sich das
sein für sich selbst und gegen das
nichts das ist natürlich eine sehr
metaphyssische Rede von Naturprodukten
wenn man sagt sie sind das sein oder
ihen zeigt sich das sein im Gegensatz
zum nichts hier spricht ja noch mal von
einem Grundwert aller Werte das in
diesem Verfolgen von Zwecken
besteht ein indifferentes sein ein sein
also etwas was nicht strebt das wäre nur
eine unvollkommenere mit dem Marel der
Sinnlosigkeit behaftete Form des Nichts
und eigentlich
unvorstellbar also so etwas was völlig
gleichgültig existiert ist für ihn
eigentlich gar nicht wirklich
denkbar im organischen Leben was bei ihm
im Zentrum steht da sagt er hat die
Natur Interesse kund gegeben also die
Natur verfolgt ein Interesse
der Interesse das zeigt sich am Zweck
und der Zweck ist immer das Streben nach
einem Ziel wie wir gesehen haben und
besteht im Unterschied zum Tod ja dass
der Tod ist immer die Gefahr der
Hintergrund vor dem sich organisches
Leben abgrenzt oder auch bemerkbar
macht ja wir können noch ein bisschen
weiterlesen er sagt das Leben ist die
explizite Konfrontation des Seins mit
dem nicht sein also wieder hier diese
sehr metaphysische Rede die so ein
bisschen an heideger erinnert eine
Existenzphilosophie der Natur Natur
Philosophie als Existenzphilosophie so
könnte man das hier
lesen jetzt kommt er auf die Rolle des
Menschen zu sprechen der Mensch steht
natürlich auch in der Evolution der
Naturprodukte der Mensch ist ein
Naturprodukt insofern wie ein Organismus
zu verstehen allerdings unterscheidet er
sich in einem wichtigen Punkt von
anderen Organismen nämlich dass er frei
ist das ist die Annahme zumindest von
Hans Jonas das sei der höchste das
höchste Ergebnis der zweckarbeit der
Natur im Menschen muss ein Naturprodukt
nicht mehr nur der Natur folgen sondern
also nicht nur sie vollstrecken die
Zwecke die Triebe die Neigungen die
anderen deterministischen Faktoren
sondern er kann sich auch gegen die
Natur selbst wenden aus der er
vorgegangen ist und das ist so ein
kritischer Punkt und darin zeigt sich
nach Hans
die Position des Menschen er musste
Natur nicht folgen obwohl er aus der
Natur stammt er kann sich sogar gegen
die Natur
wenden das haben wir jetzt soweit
gesehen Hans Jonas leitet also aus der
zweckhaftigkeit am Ende über
verschiedene Zwischenschritte auch die
Schutzbedürftigkeit der Natur
ab vitorio Hösle wie gesagt ein Schüler
von Hans Jonas der hat eine Schrift
verfasst mit dem Titel Philosophie der
ökologischen Krise die Anfang der 90er
Jahre erschienen ist und wir sehen ja
schon er verwendet nicht das Wort
anthropozen obwohl es hier gut passen
würde ne weil ökologische Krise ist
natürlich ein Zustand ind
dem die Umwelt auf dem Spiel steht das
ist Krise Krise bedeutet etwas ist an
einem Punkt angelangt wo es sich
entscheidet wo es jetzt darauf ankommt
wie es weitergeht ob es die Katastrophe
gibt oder ob es noch mal gut ausgeht man
hätte genauso gut dieses Buch nennen
können Philosophie des anthropozens aber
er nennt es Philosophie der ökologischen
Krise weil dieser Begriff damals nicht
geprägt worden war der ist ja Anfang der
2000er von Paul grrutzen also 10 Jahre
später erst nach erschein dieses Buches
geprägt worden wir haben ein paar
leidfragen schon diskutiert inwiefern
kritisiert Hösle kannsethik also
kannsethik steht hier im Hintergrund
verknüpftte an sie an dann wie möchte
Hösel einen dritten Weg ein
Alternativweg zwischen dem was er ein
munismus des Seins nennt und dem was er
einen Dualismus zwischen Fakten und
Normen nennt entwickeln und beschreiten
wie gelingt ihm das gelingt ihm das
überhaupt oder wie sieht er aus und dann
wie verhält sich seine Argumentation im
Vergleich zur derjenigen von Hans Jonas
er grrenzt sich nämlich davon ab
natürlich muss man sich dann immer
fragen ob diese Argumentation auch
überzeugend ist man muss sie kritisch
betragen auch hier bringe ich jetzt ein
paar zentrale Zitate so ein bisschen im
Schnelldurchlauf habe aber die
wichtigsten Passagen darin wieder fett
markiert und darüber sprechen wir jetzt
ein bisschen er sagt folgendes die
Naturwissenschaft da kritisiert ebenso
wie Hans Jonas die aktuelle Situation
die moderne Naturwissenschaft sie darf
ihren Gegenstand die Natur nicht auf ein
Objekt reduzieren und im jede
Subjektivität absprechen häufig wird
Natur als ein Gegenstand gefasst der der
wissenschaftlichen Betrachtung
unterliegt das ist die Kritik wir können
Sie nicht nur kausalwissenschaftlich
untersuchen nach wirkursächlichkeit
Ursache wirken sondern wir müssen auch
eine gewisse Subjektivität eine
Selbstbezüglichkeit der Natur
berücksichtigen die ihr dann auch am
Ende einen gewissen Wert zukommen lässt
der sie von einem bloßen Objekt
unterscheidet und jetzt sagt Hösle die
moderne Wissenschaft die
muss die Natur auf eine andere Weise
verstehen wie sie es bislang getan hat
und zwar indem sie ergänzt wird oder auf
Basis einer größeren umfassenderen
Theorie stattfindet und die nennt er den
Objektiven Idealismus objektiver
Idealismus steht natürlich im Kontext
der klassischen deutschen Philosophie
des subjektiven Idealismus auch des
absoluten Ismus da steckt natürlich so
ein bisschen klassische deutsche
Philosophie dahinter genau genommen auch
hegel vor
allem und er versucht jetzt eine neue
Theorie als Basis für die
Naturwissenschaft einzuführen und
deswegen machen wir jetzt einen kurzen
Exkurs zu höchstes objektiven Idealismus
was ist das eigentlich hier gibt's ein
interessantes Interview in diesem Blog
präfaktisch von Gregor Schäfer einem
lehren an der Universität Basel der hat
Herrn Hösle gefragt was der Objektive
Idealismus ist und er sagt jetzt
folgendes es geht hier darum dass wir so
etwas wie das ideale als ideale
Strukturen
annehmen die weder nur physisches sind
noch mentales ne es gibt physisches das
sind also
Naturprodukte natürliche Gegenstände das
ist physisch
und es gibt mentales das ist den unsere
Gedanken unser Wille das geistige häufig
begnügt sich die Philosophie mit diesen
zwei Bereichen nicht selten reduziert
sich sogar das mentale auf das physische
etwa auf unser Gehirn Hösle geht jetzt
noch einen Schritt weiter und sagt wir
müssen nicht nur das physische vom
mentalen unterscheiden und annehmen als
existieren wir brauchen auch noch ein
dritte Sphäre und das ist die Sphäre des
idealen und die ideale Welt ist etwas
was wir erkennen können was aber nicht
empirischer Natur ist also ist nichts
was jetzt durch Naturwissenschaft
erforscht werden kann ja das ist jetzt
natürlich eine spannende Frage was das
genau ist und hier bringt er so ein paar
Argumente er sagt dass
wir Werte plausiebe machen können indem
wir den Objektiven ideal muss annehmen
und um die Werte geht's jetzt ja auch
hier es geht um den Wert der Natur und
Hösle möchte durch sein objektiven
Idealismus zeigen dass der Natur ein
Wert
zukommt ja hier bringt er eben noch mal
sein Buch Philosophie der ökologischen
Krise von 1991 10 Jahre vor der
begriffsprägung des anthopzäns und er
versucht zu zeigen dass sein objektiver
Idealismus gerade für dieses
Umweltproblem eine Lösung anbieten kann
das war jetzt der ganz kurze Exkurs zum
objektiven Idealismus wir fahren weiter
lesen weiter in sein Text über die
ökologische Krise und er sagt jetzt
folgendes er knüpft an Kant an und sagt
das normative Sätze als Sätze die ein
Gebot enthalten ein sollen ausdrücken
nicht aus deskriptiven Sätzen also
beschreibenden Sätzen abgeleitet werden
können so hatte auch Hans Jonas
angefangen mit diesem Problem V sein und
sollen das natürlich auf David hum
zurückgeht da mache ich dann auch oben
rechts ein Link zu einem Seminar zu
diesem Thema hinein ja er möchte jetzt
also wie kann zwischen diesen beiden
Bereich unterscheiden er möchte aber
zugleich sowas wie eine dualistische
Ontologie also eine Lehre vom sein was
in zwei Bereiche zerfällt die nicht
miteinander vereinbar sind die möchte er
vermeiden die
Welt ein und die Welt der Normen die
sollen miteinander
zusammenhängen er sagt innerhalb einer
solchen Ontologie muss ja die empirische
Welt zu der auf die Natur gehört
notwendig ein eigenen Dignität Dignität
ist die würde entbehren wenn also die
Natur nur auf dem Bereich des
deskriptiven reduziert wird dann können
wir ihr keine Werthaftigkeit zuschreiben
aber das brauchen wir gerade im
Zeitalter der ökologischen Krise das ist
jetzt also seine thesee er möchte jetzt
aber nicht und das ist der entscheidende
Punkt zurück zu Hans Jonas dem er eine
aristotelisierende Ontologie unterstellt
also ein Monismus des sein sagt er auch
noch später das also aus der Natur
heraus der Wert sich entwickelt durch
zweckhaftigkeit das glaubt er geht nicht
er möchte also nicht nur diesen Monismus
des Seins vertreten den er ans Jonas
zuspricht
ähm er möchte aber auch nicht so ein
Dualismus wie er ih kannt ähm
unterstellt zwischen Norm und Fakten
vertreten sondern er vertritt die These
dass das Sittengesetz also das ideale
die Norm die wir von Kant kennen die
empirische Welt prinzipieriert was heißt
jetzt prinzipieriert dass sie ihr
Prinzip ist dass sie ihr zugrunde liegt
also er versucht nicht aus der Natur die
Werte abzuleiten indem die Natur ansetzt
s setzt der Natur noch mal was voraus
und das ist eben diese Ideale Sphäre die
durch seinen objektiven Idealismus
denkmöglich geworden ist ja er sagt die
das sengesetz gehört einer eigen idealen
welelt an aber es ist nichts ontologisch
radikal anderes gegenüber der
natürlichen Welt das wäre dieser
Dualismus und jetzt kommt's weil es viel
mehr ihr Grund ist das sengesetz ist ist
der Grund der Natur ja es ist der Grund
der Natur
m die am Ende zu Menschen hinführt der
Werte erkennen kann das ist seine These
schon im ersten Organismus sagt er
bricht eine Differenz zwischen ist und
soll auf die sich in der Wicklung von
Pflanze Tier und Mensch immer mehr
vertieft und dann am Ende zu Menschen
führt der selbst ein W Bewusstsein
entwickeln kann ja die Pflanze ist das
unterste die unterste Stufe dann kommen
höhere Organismen Tiere die wiederum auf
organische Substanzen angewiesen sind
und so steigert sich von Lebensform zu
Lebensform die Subjektivität je mehr sie
sich von der ihr umgebenden Natur
abgrenzt ja das ist so seine These ähm
und ähm wir lesen noch ein bisschen
weiter
ähm die Natur sagt er jetzt hier und das
wieder als eine Korrektur von kanzethik
verstehen auch die Natur ist
objektitlicher Pflicht sie ist ein
Gegenstand sittlicher Pflichten wir
müssen die Natur
respektieren sie hat auch eine Forderung
an uns wir müssen uns ihr gegenüber
verpflichtet fühlen warum dies folgt
daraus dass sie an den idealen
Strukturen
partizipiert sie verwirklicht Werte und
diese Werte dürfen nicht nur ohne Not
zerstört werden also die Natur selbst
ist fundiert in dieser idealen Struktur
und weil sie aus ihr hervorgeht enthält
sie auch Werte die wir nicht direkt
erkennen aber zumindest
vermittelt
ja hier sagt noch was interessantes er
fragt nach dem Verhältnis von Natur und
Geist und da sagt er jetzt dass das
Leben eines Menschen stets höer steht
als das Leben eines jeden Tieres ist der
Mensch vielleicht nicht auch ein Tier
kann man sich fragen ne warum denn wenn
auch in jedem Organismus sich werthafte
wirklich so ist doch das werthafte in
jenem Wesen das alleine die wertfrage zu
stellen vonm dem organisch werthaften
unendlich überlegen ja also der Mensch
ist deswegen das Wertvollste was in der
Natur gibt überhaupt gibt in der Welt
zumindest weil der Mensch die Frage nach
dem Wert auf werfen kann was nach kann
die übrige Natur nicht kann das ist für
ihn hier
dieser Argument er möchte aber dennoch
keinen schlechten anthropozentrismus
vertreten wir hatten die verschiedenen
Positionen diskutiert anthropozentrismus
bedeutet nur der Mensch ist in der Natur
wertvoll dann gibt's noch andere
Positionen den physiozentrismus alles
belebte hat ein Wert also nicht nur der
Menschen auch Pflanzen oder Tiere
patozentris
nur das leidensfähige ist wertvoll also
Mensch und Tiere und D gibt noch den
Holismus alles in der Welt ist wertvoll
da ist so eine Mischung zwischen
Holismus und
anthopozentrismus ja er sagt nämlich wir
dürfen nicht einfach die Natur beliebig
zerstören warum weil das natürliche
Resultat eines Jahrmillionen währenden
Selektionsprozesses ist und in dies
Prozess zeigt sich eine differenzierthit
also eine
Ausgestaltung die ganz viel natürliche
Weisheit enthält sodass ihre Vernichtung
nur dann moralisch sein kann wenn sie
etwa menschliches Leben bewahren hil er
denkt jetzt hier die ccpliege die eine
Plage ist weil sie Krankheiten
übertringt also die Natur enthält auch
Weisheit weil sie selbst eine Form von
Entwicklung durchmacht und dann auch zu
gewissen Wissen gelangt das ist
natürlich eine sehr
voraussetzungsreiche Theorie der
Evolution der nicht alle
evolutionsbiologinnen und Biologen
zustimmen werden vermute ich ja er sagt
wir dürfen also nicht einfach die Natur
zerstören das muss immer sehr sehr
kritisch betrachtet werden und er sagt
auch dass
ähm nicht nur die Natur als solche
betrachtet werden muss S auch die
ästhetischen Schäden dass also auch die
Natur eine gewisse Schönheit besitzt die
nicht zerstört werden
darf ja Natürlichkeit ist kein
geltungskriterium als solches da folgt
erkannt aber dennoch nimmt er so eine
innere Zweckmäßigkeit an die jedem
organischen gegenüber den bloß
künstlichen den Artefakten also
Maschinen und so weiter die sie
auszeichnet
das ist die Selbstbestimmung Organismen
beziehen sich auf sich selbst während äh
das für ein Artefakt von Maschinen nicht
gilt jetzt kann man sich natürlich
neuerdings fragen ob nicht auch
künstliche neuronale Netze so eine
Subjektivität besitzen weil sich ja auch
auf sich selbst beziehen durch
fehlerrückkopplung ja das wäre noch zu
diskutieren im 21
Jahrhundert ja wie sollen wir also jetzt
die Natur als Objekt sittlicher sichten
verstehen hier sagt er wir müssen es
analogisch zu unserem Verhältnis zu
Kinder verstehen Kinder sind nicht fähig
Pflichten zu verstehen ebenso wie die
Natur und auch nicht zu befolgen aber
wir können Sie im Sinne eines
Vormundes dafür äh schützen ja wir
können für Sie die Verantwortung
übernehmen äh weil sie eben noch nicht
reif genug sind also analogisch zum Kind
analog zum Kind sollen wir auch die
Natur
schützen
ja zum Schluss geht's noch um die Frage
welche Bedeutung jetzt die Menschheit
grundsätzlich hat es gibt ja auch
Positionen die sagen die Menschheit hat
gar kein Wert ne
m posthumanismus ist hier das Stichwort
nicht zu wechseln mit Transhumanismus
der Auffassung dass der Mensch über sich
durch künstliche Evolution hinauswachsen
soll zu einem Superwesen er sagt es ist
sogar eine Pflicht zwar nicht das
einzeln aber doch den menschlichen
Gattung das Leben weiterzugeben da
meinte natürlich das menschliche Leben
das natürlich eine starke these
und der Grund ist folgendes denn eine
Welt ohne Menschen wäre wertmäßig einer
Welt mit den Menschen absolut unterlegen
also eine Welt in der es Menschen gibt
ist absolut besser als eine Welt in der
es keine Menschen gibt die Begründung
ist weil nur Menschen ein
wertbewusstsein entwickeln können nur
ein
spür von Werten haben kann auch selbst
nur Werte aktiv setzen und begründen
kann also die Menschheit von der spricht
er die Idee des Menschen die einen
unbedingten Anspruch hat sich auch in
kommenden Generationen zu realisieren
das natürlich ein sehr aufgeladener
normativer Begriff von Menschheit der
jetzt nichts mehr mit der Gattung Homo
sapiens sapiens zu tun hat kein
biologischer Begriff das ist ein
normativer aler Begriff
gewissermaßen ja soweit der kurze
Durchlauf durch hösleses Theorie und zum
Schluss noch seine
Argumentation Prämisse deskriptiv die
Natur verfolgt Zwecke der Natur liegt
eine absolut ideale subjektive
Subjektivität zugrunde an der sie
partizipiert er sagt gemäß seinem
objektiven Idealismus prinzipieriert das
sengesetz die Natur die Natur
partizipiert daran
und jetzt kommt hier so eine normative
Prämisse die ideale Subjektivität hat
normative Geltung im Sinne des
Sittengesetzes das ist ein
wertreservoir ein ideales aber dennoch
existierendes
wertreservoir und dann kommt die
Konklusion natürliche Zwecke haben
gestuft normative Geltung gestuft bis
zum Menschen hin der die ja Krönung doch
darstellt und daausfol den auch wir
Menschen dürfen Natur nicht ohne Not
zerstören oder noch mal abgeleitet wir
müssen sie wie ein
behandeln für dass wir selbst wie ein
Vormund die Verantwortung übernehmen das
war jetzt wie gesagt höchstes
Argumentation im Gegensatz zu Hans Jonas
in der nächsten Sitzung werden wir uns
mit der Ethik der Natur der naturethik
befassen und lesen dazu einige
Übersichtsartikel aus diesem sehr
instruktiven zur kampant über naturethik
und dann das Neubuch von Angela ledika
Krebs das Weltbild der Eigel darus
werden wir auch ein paar Abschnitte
lesen und diskutieren wie sich
naturethik zu naturästhetik verhält dann
bedanke ich mich wieemals für die
Aufmerksamkeit vielleicht bis zu einer
weiteren digitalen
Folge